[Music]
welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
gonna be my new Black Panther two video
Marvel finally confirmed some big
teasers for Marvel phase four black
panthers story and a lot of you have
been asking me to talk about what's
going on with chadwick boseman there
been a lot of rumors flying around so I
will address that too if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos we're doing an Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave all your
predictions for Black Panther 2 on the
video surprisingly it's one of the few
movies that Marvel has not shifted
around it's still coming out May 20-22
that has not changed just going down the
list starting with number 5 recently the
comic book people have been doing a big
Marvel rewatch party for all the Marvel
movies when they got to Avengers endgame
the writers of the movie Markus and
McFeely confirmed that this scene from
Avengers endgame was intended to be a
big name or teaser for Marvel phase for
reading on those tremors it was a mild
subduction under the African plate do we
have a visual how are we handling it
net its earthquake under the ocean we
handle it by not handling it I think
most of us saw that scene in theaters
last year and that was the first thing
we all thought underwater earthquake off
the coast of Africa what could that
possibly be your brain suddenly
remembers Nick Fury's map from the end
of Iron Man 2 that ending scene with all
the points of interest around the world
for big Easter eggs
there was a marker right off the coast
of Africa near Wakanda smack dab in the
middle of the Atlantic Ocean and you
think Atlantis Namor hell yes here's the
funny thing too for right after Avengers
end game came out in theaters in 2019
everyone was freaking out about Namor
debuting during Marvel phase 4 it just
assumed that he would show up in Black
Panther 2 because it was a coy way who
was talking about it why else would you
write lines of dialogue teasing Namor
for a wakandan character if Namor wasn't
gonna show up in Wakanda at some point
but while everyone was pounding the
Russo brothers for answers to a bunch of
questions Easter eggs what are they
trying to set up with some of these
scenes is Iron Man really Zed is Black
Widow really dead so when everyone asks
the Russos specifically about Namor and
Black Panther 2 talking about this scene
this was their initial response they
said some people may quote-unquote
interpret it that way that it's a name
or teaser and then they go on to say but
it could also
just be an earthquake they tried to play
it off like they didn't want to confirm
or deny anything but separately back in
2018 after the first Black Panther movie
Kevin Feige confirmed that they were
trying to figure out what they wanted to
do with the name war character but he
was talking about it at a special
screening of the first Black Panther
movie why would Kevin Feige be talking
about name ordering 2018 before Avengers
endgame at a screening of the first
Black Panther movie unless they'd always
considered introducing Namor through the
Black Panther movies so three the reason
why it's important that they're setting
Namor up this way with this type of
Easter Egg in this context with this
underwater earthquake that a Koi a
seemingly doesn't care about it all why
would we worry about it it's an
underwater earthquake we handle it by
not doing anything that provides some
clear motivation for name or to hate
Wakanda so in the comics they have a
long-standing rivalry
they both raided each other's
territories the wakandans have sacked
Atlantis then later in the comics Namor
got a portion of the Phoenix force and
used its power to get revenge on the
wakandans by almost burying it in the
ocean but when it comes to the MCU
movies there has to be a very relatable
and explainable reason for Namor to want
to hate Wakanda why would he want to
attack Wakanda well maybe it's because
during this period Wakanda didn't give
them any aid and they're basically the
most powerful force in the region if not
the world because of their special
technology and their special shield
Wakanda is the most defensible country
in the world there's this whole ongoing
storyline about guilt about things
they've done in the past or haven't done
Black Panther had to deal with that
during the first movie the guilt that
his father had passed on to him for what
he done to his brother because his
brother wanted to help the Black Panther
movement in the United States all these
people around the world they could use
our technology to live a better life but
because up to that point what Condon's
had been so isolationist and black
panther's father had upheld that
tradition it became a big problem that
bit them in the ass almost literally in
the future so the fact that after the
snap Wakanda became a little more
isolationist because they lost so many
people including Black Panther himself
it would make sense that them not
lending aid to Atlantis and Namor during
that period after the snap would bite
them in the ass
again during Black Panther to somehow
but after all this I do think it's kind
of funny that right after endgame came
out the roosters were like you know it
could be Namor could be nothing could
just be an underwater earthquake and
then cut to like a couple weeks ago and
the riders like no it was definitely a
name or teaser we were definitely
setting that up part of the reason why
people at Marvel do stuff like that
where one person will say one thing and
then another producer will say something
completely different is because when
Avengers endgame was coming out in
theaters Ryan Coogler had not started to
write the Black Panther 2 movie yet so
they probably didn't want to paint him
into a corner in case he changed his
mind and didn't want to use name war in
the movie that's why they say planting
seeds sometimes they grow into things so
just because the writers of Avengers
endgame wanted to tease name war in
black panther 2 doesn't necessarily
confirm that he will show up during
Black Panther 2 all these things Kevin
Feige talking about Namor just strongly
suggests that they're trying to find a
way to bring Namor into the MCU so
number 2 what about other x-men
characters like storm what about Doctor
Doom or the Fantastic Four characters
they're been all kinds of rumors about
x-men showing up during Black Panther 2
in some way the very first place the
black panther was ever introduced in the
comics was in the Fantastic Four comics
Black Panther 2 isn't gonna drop till
Marvel phase 5 that's kind of when we're
expecting big x-men characters to show
up big Fantastic Four characters as much
as I would love to see storm show up in
Black Panther 2 I think it'd be kind of
hard to include so many new big
characters in the same movie so I feel
like you either do Namor as the
antagonist and you focus mostly on him
in the Atlanteans in that relationship
where you swap him out for someone like
storm who's kind of an antagonist for
the same type of reasons she's also a
princess of her tribe in Africa she grew
up on the western coast of Africa on the
other side of Wakanda so you could also
get into a lot of the guilt isolationism
problems that will kind of have in the
past maybe a lot of people died after
infinity war in her tribe Wakanda also
did not lend aid to them that would be
another reason for storm to hate Black
Panther at the beginning of the movie
and if we're talking about Doctor Doom
because there have been rumors that they
were considering Doctor Doom as a
villain for Black Panther 2 even though
I think that's kind of a long shot there
have been many times in the comics when
Doctor Doom has tried to conquer Wakanda
to take his vibranium everybody wants
that sweet vibranium
honey even before he died Ironman would
have loved to get his hands on some more
vibranium cañada
what what what condos I thought your
father said he got the last of it
I don't follow what comes out of Wakanda
the strongest metal on earth so part of
the logic in waiting for years to do
blacc panther2 is just to give them time
to figure out how to integrate all these
big new x-men and Fantastic Four
characters and mutants because
technically Namor isn't really an x-men
character the really cool thing about
name war though is that he is called the
first mutant because technically he
debuted in the comics before the x-men
characters so even though he's not an
x-men he is technically the very first
mutant in Marvel Comics and speaking of
mutants in the MCU there's a new rumor
that the one division TV series is
actually gonna debut both for the Falcon
and Winter Soldier series just because
it's moving along through
post-production faster I've already done
a Scarlet Witch Wanda vision trailer
video with x-men Easter eggs that
they're introducing during that series
so if we get any more footage anytime
soon then of course I'll do another one
in number one WTF I know everyone's
asking what's the deal with chadwick
boseman not that long ago he posted a
video looking like he'd been starving
himself he almost looked like he was
sick and it hadn't been that long since
Avengers end game came out so this is
what he looked like in Avengers end game
this is what he looked like in that
video the video that he posted didn't
reference any projects that he was
working on her any potential movies but
I think a lot of people are just worried
about what was going on and then there
were rumors that he might be leaving the
franchise he wasn't happy with Marvel
but those are just rumors I really don't
think that anything that big is going on
and he's probably just lost weight for
another role that he was preparing for
the reason why we probably haven't heard
about that is because of the virus
delaying everything and they're not
gonna be filming Black Panther 2 for a
long time anyway so he would bulk up
again
for Black Panther 2 it's not like he's
gonna show up at the beginning of Black
Panther 2 looking like this
and you have to remember that he's not
that huge of a dude naturally he's
already pretty slim this is a behind the
scenes video of him training for some of
those fight scenes for Black Panther
with no special effects nothing is tuned
up this is just what he looks like on a
normal day
[Music]
so even though it is weird to see him
like this
don't freak out too much it's probably
completely unrelated from what's
happening behind the scenes at Marvel
but if we get any other news about
what's going on with Marvel phase 4 or
Marvel phase 5 movies Black Panther 2 of
course I'll do a video everybody just
wants to know when we're gonna start
seeing really big x-men really big
Fantastic Four characters
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big Marvel video Seth Hogan
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details
everyone click here for my new Deadpool
3 Ryan Reynolds clip breakdown and click
here for my brand new Rick and Morty
season 4 episode 7 video thank you so
much for watching everyone stays safe
Wakanda forever
[Music]